fit off for Yoki Haru he'll flip that one to
Center Ice ABS knock it free m Kinnon gives it
up big down rumbling in on delene Save By Lucan
and that puck is somehow in his gear what a power
move by valin all the way to the front of the
cage I don't know how this was in a penalty
but Power remove his right M look at that little
backhand pass by Nathan McKinnon now as he comes
across that's stick is right up in the gloves
of Val nusi now Dalene does a smart thing he
lets the stick Ryan Galloway in that Circle Do
It All Over Again AB one at the tailes he'll
find marar McKinnon turns and fires deflected at
a save Again by up who gets the start tonight go
ahead and say it you see him in pregame skate this
morning butter soft hands just has that puck on a
string everywhere Here Comes B bursting it again
with a shot saved by Lucan and he's going to hold
on as NuSkin up the fors it comes KBS lost his
twig threw his hands in the air ABS take it away
fed off to McKinnon and he is flying down the
L A little scissor move gives it up m is in R
it a up up TR he scores he got peka looking him
down he got him out and the mooves got loose for
a smooth move right around the cage he knocks it
in two goals in two games it all starts with kale
marar winning a puck battle Nathan mckin comes
in cuts the middle every time he's on his game
and then it's the waiting game and waiting game
I thought he might have tried to stuff it short
side coming back right there but now he's way
better than my thought process buries the wrap
around as a fow player couldn't get there in time
and now m r in his back at his usual scoring Pace
yeah he came alive got back in by the Sabers and
stride molinski right to the tape of ran Johanson
it's a three onone he'll shoot oh he R it off
the the iron short side can't believe it Druid
picks up the chain malinsky filters one save look
and what that by the ABS and tar got clubbed down
almost like a cobra any chance to ounce he's
trying to take it now Ben Myers goes crashing
in Tera slides it Far Side Manson says thank you
redirected in his save by Lucen flipped up KN out
Freddy O gloved it down it's in his gear and he
takes a hit this is PETA finding the glass that's
not out again Myers pops it back now for Byam as
he walks swings it for Manson off the stick that
hits the glass ABS just dominant in the Buffalo
Zone Olson back to Bowen Byrum gives it up top
one timer safe rebound oh it's wide in the net
a backand stop and it gets through bodies score
B the chin finally hits up the puck and slams it
home for his 11th of the Season nothing leading
what a start for big bow well you're not kidding
this all started because rash stallen he's got a
bad piece of Steel he was sliding all over the
ice and there was a turnover and the ABS just
went absolute bulog after that Junkyard Dog
Style finding that clock putting it towards
the net and there's valin who I think comes on
Fresh legs with a change how Olson missed that
one I'll never know but don't worry big Bal tokin
he'll butter it up for you finds the back of a
wide open nck the avalan Zone Eric Johnson had
it knocked away but is at two on one it's wood
with the coner miles wood shoots and scores miles
wood able to rip it pass Lucan in and the ABS have
blown It Wide Open in Period number one they've
got a thre nothing lead for wood that's his Fifth
and right now the ABS are absolutely pouring it
on the Buffalo Sabers well this feels like about
three goals and right around 5 minutes I was
hoping theyd do it in the first and the half
but miles wi I think he was concerned can he
knocked that puck down flat and once it hits
there he's thinking nope I'm not going to pass it
over to Lo most three goals in 6 minutes and 30
seconds so way off their Pace from last night Dr
sent it on net and lanan almost allowed that one
to crawl up his gear but somehow they just draw
the ey of the opposition long shot there and it
hit a couple of bodies on the way in fed off for
Tes it's a quick burst from a standing start here
he comes again up to the point shot by Taves
and it's blocked away far side shot save look
at in and loose Puck is in the corner down the
boards Johansson sought some space and found
it PES off Colton snaps it up top back to Colton
one timer kick save rebound up the slot the ABS
can't collect if by Tony Granado in the cancer
battle fight right now and of course they have
an awesome sister cam gr married to Ray Ferraro
a lot of knowledge there absolutely we know the
whole family to delene he'll shoot Shan shot score
and it's Benson right down between the circles Big
save by Pros fov as darene Unleashed his third
of the Year wow the Sabres are so excited about
young Zack Benson he's only 18 years old folks
that's his third goal of the season but the way he
plays is what they love of course in the Western
Hockey League he was a superstar scor for the wiip
Pig ice 98 points his last season in Junior and
they've called him up and said you know what we
like 5 Seconds right now to go on the reant
penalty on ES skates Thompson a deep move Thompson
had it knocked away gathers it back shoots save
rebound save POS Jeff Skinner just got destroyed
by by McKennon amazing here's Nate walking in
finds m in front off the side of the net from the
car DS through dreu down the boards with it
Sabers trying to keep up here's Jack Johnson
on timer St Sam binski there it is his first
career National Hockey League goal he got to
the half boards and rocked back and Rams it
past the catching glove of UK peka Lucan rer
he's got an incredibly bright future you dream
of scoring your first National Hockey League
goal first it's the game then it's the point
and then it's the goal and you always hope
it's going to be tough shelf and a highlight
real goal and that's what Sam malinsky does
from the top of the circles by the boards you
got Rangel hson in front and that was top well
you're waiting for the scoring time touch
to come is critical to stay in the lineup
it's a recognition as well that shot never got
on net and msky lost his lid so he filled it
all the way to the point ter in with a shot
cloged by proov was it last night against
Winnipeg point two to one Pano tried to push
toward the front of the net hit Eric Johnson
quick shot at a save by Luca and that puck into
the circle L to step on that puck back to kale
goes top unit setup here's raen it looking cross
eyes mckin in front score Tic Tac to alusin his
second of the game 12th of the season and the asss
have taken a commanding 5 to one lead McKinnon
will pick up his second assist of the game and
that looked terrific it's busting through seams
M rman look at him going through two sticks mcken
right over to Val and Val he earned that goal all
night long his second of course of the night
little back door touch B literally could to
had five goals tonight I think and there's his
second of the night getting rewarded for playing
his tail off every single [__] and that was a
pretty goal to watch and no look seen pass by ran
Here Comes Freddy olon but he got stripped Zack
Benson the rookie gives it up nice pass cousins
shoots save by brosar getting that club turnout
shot save by proov he robs Tage Thompson oh Ian
proov seeing everything right now boy you
he ever and that's one of the best Shooters
Sharp Shooters in the league Tage Thompson
just unloading that PR look at him just out
he fought that one up as as are in Cup playoff
mode trying to win another and that's going to
do it here at ball Arena as Milestones are hint
emotions we're on display but it's the Avalanche